المستقبل يحمل قميصنا 10 10
حسنًا ، الصحافة هنا في أوروبا
يدعي أن باريس سان جيرمان لا يفعل ذلك
الاعتماد عليه للموسم المقبل
ومن الجنون أن أعتقد أن هذا النادي
استثمرت الكثير من الأموال في نيمار 222
ملايين الذهب من أغلى توقيع
تاريخ كرة القدم وتغييرها ككل
مشروع قائم على برازيليين لا أريدهم
الاعتماد عليه وبحسب جريدة الجريدة
سيكون البلد طلبًا من embapet متجددًا
العقد مؤخرًا وكان سيتحدث
من عدم انضباط نيمار في روتين
التدريب وكذلك في استعادة
اصابات الفرنسي ميغا وبعد ذلك يتضح ذلك
تظهر التكهنات الآن ل
تنزل لإعطاء إرادة نيمار بالطبع
هناك دائما إمكانية الذهاب إلى
سانتوس النادي الذي كشف أنه يمتلك أ
اتصال كبير جدًا ولكن أحد ملفات
مشاكل دفع الراتب المرتفع ولا
ماتا يفوز اليوم في المتوسط ​​حول نيمار
نيمار يفوز اليوم ونحو
16 مليون أي أن 16 مليون
من الريس في الشهر رائع ، من الصعب الذهاب إلى هناك
على انستغرام القوة البرازيلية الصعبة
ادفع هناك دعني قوة مونديال ثم نعم
و هناك